if you're just facing the question what
is chromebox alpha how can i calculate
it and most importantly how do i
interpret the results then you're in the
right place and we start right away with
the first question what do i actually
need grompus alpha for
let's say you have formulated a
hypothesis in which there is a variable
that cannot be measured directly a
so-called latent variable
in order to make latent variables
measurable a scale is used
so now what is a scale
a scale is a group of questions so for
example question 1 to question 4 which
are used to jointly measure a latent
variable
the individual questions in a scale are
called items
the goal now is that the responses to
the various items match well
so for example they should be highly
correlated
each individual question should
correlate as highly as possible with
every other question
if the answers to the questions are
highly correlated this is called a high
internal consistency
and now we have finally arrived at the
chromebox alpha and it is precisely this
internal consistency that chromebus
alpha measures
so we can say that chromebox alpha is a
measure of the internal consistency of a
scale
thus chromebox alpha is a measure of the
extent to which the group of questions
are related to each other
and thus it gives us an estimate of how
good or bad the measurement accuracy the
so-called reliability of a group of
items is
what is important here is that chrombus
alpha does not test whether the
individual items are really influenced
by only one
or by several latent variables
a high value of chromebus alpha is not
evidence that the items are influenced
by only one latent variable
in order to make sure that the
reliability of the scale can be
estimated using chromebox alpha the
conditions must be filled that all
questions or items measure the same
latent variable
so this means if all items measure the
same latent variable then chromeboss
alpha tells us how well these items
measure the latent variable
now first an example
our hypothesis is
extroverted people earn a higher salary
than introverted people
how do i measure the salary now that's
easy i just ask for it in my
questionnaire
so the question could be what is your
current net monthly income in dollars
but
how do i measure people's extroversion
so how do i measure people's
extroversion
let's say that through research you
found out that extroversion can be
measured by the following scale from the
big five personality traits
please indicate how strongly the
following characteristics apply to you i
am
outgoing talkative sociable enjoying
social situations and the answers range
from applies to does not apply
so now we have a scale with four items
so what you do now is you create a
survey on datadept.net and send it out
and you have the answers displayed in an
axle table
now you want to check if the items have
a high internal consistency
and calculate the chromebus alpha
you can calculate rhombus alpha with the
formulaing formula where n is the number
of items
v bar is the average variance
and c bar is the average inter-item
covariance between items
of course one does not calculate
chromebus alpha by hand
but you use a statistical software
i will now show you how to do this and
above all how to interpret the results
in order to calculate the chrombus alpha
just go to datadeb.net
and you find a link also in the video
description
then you copy your data into this table
further you just click on the link
reliability
we want to calculate the chromebox alpha
for these four items so we just click on
them
then datadeb will automatically
calculate the chromeboss alpha for us
in this case we got a chromeboss alpha
of
0.71
if we take a look at this table which
gives us an indication for the
interpretation
we find out that the calculated
chromebox alpha is just acceptable what
is further interesting now is the item
scale
statistics here we can see how the
chromebox alpha changes when one of the
four items is removed
so for example if we remove the item
outgoing we get a chromebox alpha of
0.66
which is smaller
likewise if we remove the item talkative
we get an alpha of only 0.48
however if we remove the item ensuring
social situations
we get an even higher chromebox alpha
so our chromebox alpha then would be
0.79
so in this case one could consider
removing the item enjoying social
situations
for your information this example is
freely made up
i would say just try it yourself it's
very easy
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time